J'ai jamais très bien compris les gens, le, le monde qui m'entoure. Bon, c'est l'occasion d'essayer. Je suis Guillaume Hachez, vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec.
Mais bonjour, ravi de vous retrouver. Vous l'avez sans doute remarqué, les épisodes sont devenus rares ces derniers temps, mais la bonne nouvelle, c'est que ça y est, les choses se sont alignées et il y a plein d'épisodes qui sont planifiés.
C'est bientôt les élections en Belgique, donc
pas mal de politiciens. Je vous en parle très bientôt. Mais aujourd'hui, on part sur un sujet très différent puisque j'ai reçu JoeWolf qui va nous parler d'addiction et de ses expériences passées avec les substances.
J'espère que ça vous plaira. Perso, j'ai trouvé ça très touchant et j'ai appris plein de choses. C'est parti. J'ai aujourd'hui le plaisir d'accueillir JoeWolf. Salut Joe.
Bonjour Guillaume.
Joe, tu es ici chez moi. On va parler aujourd'hui d'addiction.
Ouais.
Est-ce que tu peux te présenter un petit peu pour celles et ceux qui ne te connaissent pas encore ?
Alors sur les réseaux sociaux, c'est JoeWolf. Nonante-sept, nonante et un. Mon vrai nom, c'est Jonathan. J'ai quarante-cinq ans depuis le trois janvier.
Bruxellois ?
Bruxellois, ouais. J'ai grandi en périphérie bruxelloise pour être précis. Donc pour expliquer rapidement ce qui s'est passé, c'est que moi, j'ai eu un parcours dans l'addiction,
principalement à l'alcool, mais il y a aussi d'autres produits, des stupéfiants,
cocaïne, ecstasy.
Ça, c'était les produits principaux, mais j'ai testé d'autres trucs, les amphétamines, la codéine, quoi d'autre ? Cannabis, j'ai dit. Enfin, voilà.
Psychédéliques aussi ?
Ouais, ouais, les champignons aussi. Jamais de LSD, des champignons, oui. J'ai commencé à consommer de l'alcool, j'avais quatorze ans, mais c'était pour les vacances.
Et vers dix-huit ans, l'alcool, c'est devenu beaucoup plus régulier. J'ai commencé le cannabis. Le cannabis, ça a été directement caisse.
Ça a été directement une consommation régulière. J'ai arrêté l'école, j'avais vingt ans. J'étais en train de tripler ma cinquième secondaire.
Il y a eu une histoire aussi avec une histoire de harcèlement, d'agress— enfin une tentative d'agression de racket, dont un des gars faisait partie de l'école.
Donc échec scolaire plus ça, machin. Voilà, avec ma mère, on a décidé que le parcours scolaire était terminé. Et assez rapidement, j'ai commencé à travailler chez Renault comme aide magasinier.
Et là, l'alcool, c'est devenu quotidien.
D'accord, OK.
Le cannabis, c'est resté. Et voilà, les autres produits, c'est à l'occasion. Mais toutes les occasions étaient bonnes.
On va avoir l'occasion d'explorer un petit peu tout ça parce que t'as, t'as l'air d'avoir exploré toi-même pas mal de choses.
Quand même.
Si je devais poser la question très naïvement, très simplement, qu'est-ce qui a été le déclencheur en fait pour toi ?
Par exemple, pour l'alcool, au-dessus des dix-huit ans, tu commences à beaucoup consommer.
L'alcool, même le cannabis, le reste aussi un petit peu quelque part, ça a commencé en primaire, le harcèlement.
On en parlait—
On n'en parlait pas.
On n'en parlait pas. On n'en parlait pas. C'est pas comme— et tant mieux qu'on en parle beaucoup plus maintenant, que la parole s'est libérée par rapport à ça.
D'autant plus qu'aujourd'hui, il y a les réseaux sociaux, mais enfin, soit. Pas beaucoup d'amis, j'étais un peu la tête de Turc, on se moquait de moi, je comprenais pas pourquoi.
Enfin bref, la consommation d'alcool, ça a commencé surtout pour créer du lien social, en fait.
C'est intéressant que tu dises ça. Parce que c'est un truc qui revient assez régulièrement, justement, chez les personnes, disons, je vais dire, introverties ou un peu pas complètement à l'aise socialement ou ce genre de profil là.
Et je vais souvent entendre ce truc de : « Ah, mais moi, je bois pour être un peu décondensé, un peu plus à l'aise, parce que les gens me trouvent sympa quand je bois.
Et donc, je continue à boire. »
Bah en fait, introverti, moi, j'étais pas trop.
OK.
Parce que j'ai toujours eu ce côté un peu, je vais dire clown pour, tu vois, vraiment schématiser, résumer très vite le truc.
Donc j'avais pas trop de problèmes à ce niveau-là. C'était vraiment le côté social pour être avec des gens, en fait. Avoir un groupe d'amis.
D'accord, OK, OK.
Avec ce centre d'intérêt commun qui est la consommation dans un premier temps d'alcool. Et le cannabis, ça a été pareil.
Ça a été le même mécanisme.
J'ai oublié de préciser, moi, je suis enfant unique. J'ai été élevé seul par ma maman. Donc à la maison, il y avait— je parlais de sentiment de solitude, mais c'est peut-être un peu exagéré parce que, mais bon, il y avait quand même ça.
À l'école, je suis pas accepté. Donc ça a été ma première stratégie, si tu veux, pour créer du lien social avec des gens qui vont pas se moquer de moi parce que je suis trop grand, je suis trop maigre, je suis trop ceci, je suis trop cela.
Et puis voilà, moi, j'ai un pote, il m'a une fois dit : « Toi, t'es bon client, t'es bon délire. » J'ai jamais eu une consommation d'alcool où je devenais violent, des trucs comme ça.
J'ai toujours été dans la rigolade, en fait.
Ouais, ça devient un peu ton identité, du coup.
Ouais, voilà, c'est ça.
T'es bon délire, t'es sympa.
Ouais, voilà. Ces personnes-là, elles s'étrennaient avec moi parce que j'étais sympa, je rigolais. J'ai quand même un solide sens de l'humour.
J'ai différents types d'humour. Moi, j'aime bien rigoler de tout et de rien. Les consommations m'ont permis de créer du lien social, en fait, et de pouvoir me rapprocher de personnes qui avaient un peu les mêmes centres d'intérêt que moi,
hors que la consommation.
Parce que très rapidement, ben je me suis lié d'amitié avec des gens qui aimaient comme moi le basket, par exemple, ou le hip-hop ou des trucs comme ça.
Donc ça me permettait vraiment d'avoir, je vais dire le mot émulation, tu vois, pour dire voilà, on était entre nous et on rigolait bien, etc, etc.
J'ai interrompu ton autobiographie, mais du coup, dans l'histoire plus récente de Jonathan, il y a le fait que tu en parles maintenant publiquement sur TikTok, notamment.
Notamment, ouais.
C'est comme ça que je t'ai découvert. Aujourd'hui, est-ce que tu dirais que tu l'as sous contrôle ? Que tu parles de ça au passé ?
Ouais, ouais, c'est le passé. Oui, oui, c'est le passé. Ça fait partie de mon parcours, en fait. Je l'assume. J'ai connu ça.
Je suis en parcours de rétablissement. Je pense que je suis bien stabilisé dans mon rétablissement. Je suis bien dans mes pompes.
Je le dis très humblement, mais j'ai bien travaillé en thérapie, j'ai fait ce qu'il fallait en hospitalisation. Depuis la sortie d'hospitalisation, je continue à être suivi.
J'étais pas spécialement le meilleur des élèves à l'école, mais en tout cas, dans ce parcours-là, je suis très assidu. Je fais ce qu'on me dit de faire.
Enfin, j'écoute en tout cas les conseils. Tiens, essayez de faire ça. Je vais essayer, ça me convient, je continue. Ça me convient pas, je trouve autre chose.
Donc, je te demandais si tu parlais de tout ça au passé.
Bon, je sais que ça a l'air d'être une bête question sémantique, mais je pense que c'est assez révélateur. Tu dirais : j'ai été un addict ou tu en parlerais encore au présent en disant que c'est encore présent chez toi, l'addiction ?
Ta question est super intéressante parce que justement, je me suis posé la question très récemment.
Voilà, donc j'ai fait l'hospitalisation, j'ai participé à des groupes de paroles. En sortant d'hospit', j'étais dans un groupe de paroles, mais un groupe de paroles ouvert dans l'association où je vais, Le Pélican.
Bon, le groupe, je sais plus y aller, la formation, etc. Bla bla bla. Donc, il fallait que je trouve un nouveau groupe. J'ai testé un autre groupe, c'est une fois par mois, donc c'est un peu peu.
Et finalement, je me suis décidé à aller aux Narcotiques Anonymes.
D'accord.
Les Alcooliques Anonymes, ça marche aussi comme ça. Quand tu te présentes, c'est : bonjour, je m'appelle Jonathan, je suis dépendant.
Et tous les autres participants disent la même chose : bonjour, je m'appelle untel, je suis dépendant.
Oui. C'est l'acceptance.
Ouais, c'est ça.
On reconnaît—
Mais moi, j'avais déjà accepté ma maladie. Moi, je suis dans mon parcours de rétablissement, dix-huit mois, maintenant dix-neuf, bientôt vingt mois de sobriété.
Enfin, tu vois, j'étais dans une mécanique, dans une approche comme ça de ma maladie, de ma dépendance, enfin, de tout ça.
Je dis : mais pourquoi je devrais aller dire que je suis dépendant ? Mais je suis plus dépendant. Moi, j'ai fait un sevrage, deux fois en hospit', deux ans de thérapie.
Et en fait, ils ont raison parce que je serai dépendant toute ma vie. J'ai vraiment pris conscience de ça. J'ai vraiment encore plus accepté.
Je dois me présenter en disant : voilà, je m'appelle Jonathan, je suis dépendant. Je peux préciser alcolo-dépendant abstinent, toxicomane abstinent.
Enfin, j'aime pas le mot toxicomane, mais enfin, bref, s'il faut l'employer. Mais je vois là, je suis en abstinence, mais je sais très bien que si demain, je bois une gorgée d'une bière—
Ça va pas le faire. Derrière, ça va être catastrophe.
Un joint, je peux même pas te— je sais que si je tire une taffe sur un joint dans une soirée, le lendemain, je redépense dix balles quoi, et ce sera reparti.
Donc en ça, oui, je suis alcolo-dépendant abstinent, mais je, voilà. Toute ma vie, je sais que je devrais faire attention, je devrais toujours rester vigilant à ça, en fait.
Je sais très bien que voilà, c'est comme ça.
Ton mot préféré, alors, ce serait alcolo-dépendant, addict ?
Je suis, ouais, je suis une personne sujette aux addictions.
Oui, OK.
Et le problème, c'est aussi l'excès.
Ça, c'est un truc qui revient souvent chez les personnes qui ont un problème d'addiction et ça peut faire addiction au sexe, au jeu aussi, faut... Il y a pas qu'une—
Il y a pas que l'alcool et les stupéfiants. Souvent, il y a la notion d'excès aussi qui vient derrière.
Et en fait, cette relation à l'excès ou à la dopamine, finalement.
Oui, oui, oui.
Tu dirais que c'est, tu es né comme ça ou bien est-ce que c'est l'exposition aux substances qui a amené ça chez toi ?
C'est complexe, en fait. Tu vas pas naître addict. C'est quelque chose qui va se développer sur plusieurs années. Ça, je l'ai compris vraiment avec deux psys.
En fait, c'est une stratégie, l'addiction. Toi, moi, tout le monde, en règle générale, on vit des trucs un peu traumatisants.
Harcèlement, un deuil, divorce des parents, perte d'un emploi, ça peut aller loin, tu vois, les coups de la vie quoi.
Et ce qui se passe, c'est que la personne va chercher des stratégies pour encaisser ces coups-là, pour vivre dans le monde extérieur.
Je l'explique comme ça, moi. Et t'en as, ça va être de se plonger dans les études. J'ai d'ailleurs entendu quelqu'un récemment expliquer : moi, j'ai vécu ça, ça, ça.
Je suis devenu le meilleur élève de ma classe. Il y en a, ils vont se passionner pour le sport. Ils vont trouver des trucs pour passer le temps, pour se créer du lien social, etc., etc.
Et puis, tu en as d'autres qui vont trouver comme stratégie la consommation d'alcool, de stupéfiants. C'est une stratégie qui marche directement.
T'as pas besoin de t'entraîner.
Tu veux être bon à l'école, il faut bosser. Tu veux être fort en mécanique, il faut bosser. Et le résultat, tu l'as pas directement.
Mais quand tu consommes de l'alcool, le résultat est immédiat. T'as pas besoin qu'on t'entraîne. Enfin, tu vois, t'as pas besoin d'un coach, t'as pas besoin de grande pratique, ça marche direct.
Et voilà, comme c'est directement efficace, tu continues là-dedans en fait. Moi, c'est ce qui s'est passé. J'ai trouvé ça directement très efficace.
Ah bah oui, je me suis directement fait des potes, la désinhibition, tu vois. Et puis après—
Donc, la stratégie de coping ou de compensation, voilà, face à des états difficiles dans la vie, est-ce qu'on est tous et toutes égaux face à des situations comme ça et face à l'exposition—
Non.
À des substances comme ça ou bien est-ce que—
Il va aussi y avoir ton milieu environnemental.
Oui.
On dit souvent, c'est l'expression qui revient souvent, on est le produit de notre environnement.
Et ça, c'est vrai aussi. Tout va dépendre aussi dans quel milieu tu grandis. Le fait de voir autour de toi des adultes, par exemple, qui vont consommer de l'alcool.
Moi, je me rappelle très bien, dans ma famille, les gens consommaient de l'alcool. Pas de façon excessive, j'ai pas de souvenir d'avoir vu quelqu'un dans ma famille tomber en dessous de la table, tu vois.
Mais voilà, tu vois des adultes qui consomment de l'alcool, ça leur pose pas de problème, ça rigole. Donc à un moment donné, tu te dis : bah pourquoi pas tester puisque ça a l'air marrant.
Il y a de ça. Tes fréquentations, ça joue aussi pour beaucoup. Il y a aussi un, comment je vais dire ça, un phénomène d'identification.
Tu vois, tu sais quand tu vis quelque chose dans ta vie, soit tu le reproduis à l'identique, soit tu pars à l'opposé aussi.
Il y a ça aussi à prendre en ligne de compte.
Il y en a qui vont me dire, il y a aussi un facteur génétique, mais le facteur génétique, il est très très très très faible.
OK. Donc toi, tu suivrais pas tellement cet axe-là. Je pose la question en fait, parce que, pendant les fêtes, j'avais eu l'occasion d'écouter, c'était la biographie de Matthew Perry.
Ouais.
Donc Chandler dans Friends qui justement était aussi addict et qui parle dans son livre de sa relation à l'alcool et au...
Comment s'appelle encore ce truc qu'ils prennent aux États-Unis ?
Les opiacés.
Voilà, exactement, exactement. Et donc on sait qu'il est mort, il a été retrouvé dans sa piscine avec une dose trop importante de kétamine.
Ouais.
Et un truc qui m'avait marqué dans ce qu'il racontait, c'était, il parlait pas tellement d'une enfance triste, d'un milieu difficile.
Il était plutôt stable socialement et tout ça. Mais il parle de ce moment où pour la première fois,
quand il était trop jeune pour acheter de l'alcool, il arrive à s'en procurer avec ses deux potes et ils vont dans un jardin et ils ouvrent la bouteille et commencent à boire ensemble.
Et il explique à quel point ses deux potes passaient juste un moment sympa à rigoler et que lui, il a eu ce truc où il sentait que son cerveau a eu une espèce de déclic de : oh, il me faut ça
Ouais, ouais, ouais, ouais
encore.
Ouais. Oui, oui, oui.
Et en entendant ça, je me disais : Ah ouais, OK. Donc c'est— y a peut-être quand même un truc de...
Je sais pas si ça— ouais, je pense qu'il y a un lien avec ça. Moi, j'aimais ça. J'ai déjà expliqué à plusieurs reprises que moi, je voyais la défonce, je parle de la défonce en règle générale, comme un hobby.
C'était une passion pour moi. J'aimais fondamentalement ça, j'aimais être saoul, j'aimais être stone, j'aimais être sous cocaïne.
Il y avait vraiment— c'était un centre d'intérêt quoi. Et, comme tu dis, il y a quelque chose qui se passe dans le cerveau.
Le cerveau, il y a des gens, le cerveau va se retrouver sous alcool et ils vont faire : le cerveau va faire « Beuh ».
Mmh.
Et puis t'en as d'autres, pour un tas de raisons différentes, ça va faire : « Waouh ! » Comme t'as dit, comme Matthew Perry, il explique.
C'est waouh. Tu découvres un monde, en fait. Tu vois, c'est... L'autre jour, j'ai encore vu un Chicandier. C'est un humoriste acteur français.
OK.
Il a eu de graves problèmes avec l'alcool et il disait : « Moi, quand j'ai découvert l'alcool, je comprends même pas pourquoi on n'est pas dans cet état-là en permanence ».
Ouais, il y en a même eu certains qui ont théorisé qu'il fallait tout le temps une microdose d'alcool pour être stabilisé.
Ouais, ça, c'est après. Mais voilà, il y a de ça. Tu découvres un truc, en fait, c'est fantastique quoi, tu vois.
C'est la convivialité, la dopamine. Et puis c'est très ritualisé aussi. Il y a aussi parfois cette recherche d'adrénaline, braver l'interdit.
Ouais, c'est ça. Ouais, il y a un aspect un peu social et...
Ouais, ouais, il y a tout un truc-
Psychologique, ouais.
...par exemple, moi, je me rappelle très bien, quand tu vas chercher des stupéfiants, il y a cette espèce d'adrénaline, tu vois.
Il y a le danger. Aujourd'hui, ça a tout à fait changé hein, c'est devenu beaucoup plus, je vais dire, open bar, c'est très facile de se trouver tout et n'importe quoi.
Mais moi, à mon époque, dans les années 2000, c'était un peu underground. Il fallait connaître quelqu'un, il fallait parfois aller dans des quartiers un peu louches, tu vois, tu sais, un peu chauds.
Braver l'interdit quoi.
Ouais, donc t'allais là, tu te mettais un peu en danger en allant dans des quartiers un peu bizarres et puis t'attendais le gars.
Ça aussi, tu vois, l'attente du dealer, le mec arrive, tu récupères ton truc et hopaa.
Parce que tu sais qu'en rentrant, tu vas avoir ton plaisir, mais il y a même du plaisir en rentrant en te disant : « Il faut que je fasse attention ouais, la police, machin ».
C'est vraiment très ritualisé et tu peux même devenir accro au rituel aussi hein. Moi, je pense que j'étais vraiment accro aussi au rituel d'appeler, de ci, de ça.
Il y a plein de mécaniques qui se mettent en place. Et voilà, après, c'est très compliqué parce que déjà, les produits en eux-mêmes provoquent une addiction, mais les rituels, les habitudes aussi, tu vois.
Ouais, ouais.
Donc ça peut être très compliqué de casser le cercle vicieux.
Tu parles vraiment de situations, un état émotionnel, un état social compliqué, tout ça. L'aspect génétique, toi, tu pas trop... Ouais.
C'est pas que j'y crois pas. Il y a une part, mais moi, je pense que c'est plus ton environnement.
OK.
Et ce que tu vas vivre dans ta vie d'enfant, d'adolescent et même d'adulte qui va faire qu'à un moment donné, pour passer un cap difficile, tu vas te tourner vers de l'alcool ou des stupéfiants.
La génétique, c'est vraiment, pour moi, de ce que j'en sais, c'est vraiment un tout petit peu.
Là où moi, j'ai encore des doutes, c'est précisément sur ce que tu disais, sur le fait que certains cerveaux, entre guillemets, vont faire : « Beuh » et d'autres vont faire : « Uh », encore, encore.
Là, je sais pas si c'est psychologique, je sais pas si c'est construit. Je pense qu'il y a peut-être un...
C'est, c'est-
C'est dur à dire hein. Je pense que c'est un peu de tout.
Ouais, c'est un mélange, c'est vraiment un amalgame un petit peu de tout. Une personne n'est pas l'autre. On n'est pas tous égaux face aux substances. Voilà.
Enfin bon, on parle un petit peu de choses qu'on maîtrise moyennement, mais donc je vais revenir sur ce qu'on connaît bien.
Qu'est-ce qui t'a amené à prendre la parole publiquement, en fait, aujourd'hui, sur TikTok ?
Alors, ce qui s'est passé, donc j'arrive à la clinique, je reçois mon premier-- je pense que c'est au premier Valium.
Au premier ou deuxième Valium, je ne sais plus. Le Valium, ça assomme hein. Je sais pas pourquoi, je vais dans la salle de bain et je vois ma tête et je fais : « Waouh ».
Je sais pas, il y a un truc qui m'a traversé l'esprit. J'ai pris mon téléphone, j'ai fait un TikTok en disant : « Voilà, si vous voulez pas
vous retrouver dans cette situation-là qui consiste à être dans une chambre d'hôpital psychiatrique, dans une clinique dédiée aux addictions, avec des Valiums dans la tronche, faites attention à ce que vous prenez.
Si vous pouvez éviter l'alcool et les stupéfiants. » Je me suis dit : « C'est intéressant de faire passer ce message-là » parce que de base, TikTok, voilà, c'est une application vraiment pour les plus jeunes.
En fait, tout le monde est sur TikTok.
Les gens disent c'est pour les plus jeunes.
Toutes les tranches d'âge sont présentes sur TikTok. D'ailleurs, moi, les retours que j'ai, j'ai des très jeunes, des moyennement jeunes.
Enfin, j'ai des personnes de 60 ans qui me contactent. Et je me suis dit : « Ce serait intéressant de parler de ça pour prévenir les gens qu'en fait...
» Moi, je dis, c'est ce que je dis tout le temps : « Il n'y a pas de maladie honteuse ». L'alcoolisme, l'addiction aux stupéfiants, c'est une maladie.
Il n'y a pas de maladie honteuse. Il faut pas avoir honte. Il faut déstigmatiser le truc. Et il y a pas de honte à demander de l'aide pour se rétablir.
Si vous sentez que vous avez un problème avec l'alcool, allez en parler à un médecin. Posez-vous les bonnes questions, faites attention.
Si maintenant, vous voulez absolument consommer un truc, je vous préviens, il va se passer ça, ça et ça.
Au départ, c'était très impulsif, finalement.
Ouais, ouais, c'est-
C'était sur un coup de tête, de faire. Et quoi ? Immédiatement, t'as eu des retours et ça t'a donné envie de continuer ou... ?
Immédiatement, peut-être pas, mais rapidement, en tout cas, il y a des questions qui sont arrivées sur les commentaires des vidéos.
Parce que j'ai commencé aussi à parler, comme j'apprenais. On sait tous plus ou moins ce que c'est la cocaïne. On sait tous plus ou moins ce que c'est le cannabis.
Mais il y a beaucoup de fausses idées, d'idées reçues sur les produits. On minimise souvent l'impact du cannabis sur la santé.
Étant donné que je commençais à avoir plein d'informations, j'ai commencé à partager ces informations, à faire un petit peu une espèce de journal de bord aussi, tu vois, avec TikTok.
Et donc de là, j'ai commencé à recevoir des questions, j'ai commencé à répondre. Et c'est comme ça que la mayonnaise, entre guillemets, a pris.
Et puis, il y a beaucoup de personnes qui m'ont contacté en message privé. Donc là, j'ai commencé un petit peu à leur expliquer.
Et sans m'en rendre compte, je faisais déjà de la pair-aidance, en fait. Donc c'est-à-dire aider mes pairs. Et c'est comme ça, en fait, par après, en hospitalisation, que j'ai découvert le,
je vais dire, le concept de pair aidant.
Ces publications que tu mets sur TikTok, est-ce que tu dirais que ça t'a aidé ou ça t'aide dans ta propre lutte vis-à-vis de ton addiction ?
Ouais. En fait, je dis souvent, c'est un rematrixage. On me pose souvent la question : ça te dérange pas de parler de ça, de ça, de ça ?
Je dis non. En parler ne va pas me provoquer de crise d'envie déjà. Et puis c'est pour vraiment me rappeler, tu vois, que si je reprends ça, il va se passer ça
et que je vais de nouveau me retrouver en crise d'angoisse, je vais de nouveau faire de la parano et je vais de nouveau faire ci.
Et ça, j'en ai plus envie. J'en ai clairement plus envie. J'ai envie de vivre autrement. Donc ça fait aussi un petit peu partie de mon parcours de rétablissement.
Je pense très sincèrement, ça a servi de thérapie.
Et donc tu as commencé ça il y a combien de temps ?
En juin 2022. Puisque je suis rentré en hospitalisation le 2 juin, donc vraiment début juin 2022, j'ai commencé. Donc c'est très récent.
L'hospitalisation en juin 2022.
En fait, ce qui se passe-
C'était suite à un épisode en particulier ?
En fait, ce qui se passe, je pense qu'on était en novembre 2021. Il y avait une rupture avec mon ex-compagne. Ça faisait dix ans qu'on était ensemble.
La rupture se passe très très mal. Dans la foulée, ma grand-mère décède. Je dois déménager. J'emménage au-dessus de mon boulot.
Mauvaise idée, mais bon, soit. Le lendemain où ma compagne est partie vivre ailleurs, j'ai racheté du cannabis.
J'ai consommé beaucoup plus de-- enfin, j'ai jamais arrêté de boire, mais là, j'en ai consommé plus que ce que je ne faisais avant.
J'ai commencé à boire de l'alcool fort, enfin de la vodka, des trucs comme ça.
Et tu avais arrêté le cannabis depuis quand ?
Dix ans.
J'avais arrêté toutes les-- en fait, j'ai fait une rechute dans le cannabis et la cocaïne quoi, après dix ans. Je suis la tête dans le guidon, en fait.
Je me voile un peu la face. Enfin, tu vois, je suis un bonhomme, moi, j'ai quarante-trois ans, quarante-deux ans, moi, je sais vivre.
Tu vois, je gère, je gère.
Oui, c'est ça.
Le grand mot, je gère. En fait, je gérais rien du tout. Et ce qui se passe, c'est en novembre 2021, je pense. Parce qu'à un moment donné, quand tu fais un burn out, en fait, tu es dans le flou au niveau de la timeline.
Et donc je fais un burn out. Et ça, c'est le premier déclic. J'en ai parlé l'autre fois en vidéo. Pour moi, ma vie était terminée.
Quand tu fais un burn out, c'est ton corps et ton esprit qui te lâchent en même temps. Et je voyais plus l'avenir au-delà de cinq minutes.
Et là, je sais pas, instinct de survie, sursaut d'orgueil, probablement un peu des deux. Je me dis : Non, c'est pas possible.
J'ai quarante et un ans, quarante-deux ans, à peu près à ce moment-là, et je me projette dans le futur, en fait. Et je me dis
: Si je continue comme ça, dans cinq ans, je vais commencer à avoir les cales qui se touchent et dans dix ans, je me rappellerai à peine de comment je m'appelle.
Je me dis : il faut que je fasse quelque chose, je ne peux plus vivre comme ça. Je ne veux plus vivre comme ça, c'est terminé.
Donc, je vais chez mon médecin généraliste, entre guillemets, c'est elle qui a été le premier petit peu déclencheur, enfin, prise de conscience.
Enfin, tu vois, qui m'a vraiment bien aiguillé, qui m'a vraiment donné des infos capitales pour mon rétablissement. Elle me dit-
Catalyseur du...
Ouais, ouais, ouais, elle m'a écouté. Elle m'a écouté, elle m'a laissé-
T'as plus mal t'en vais, t'as plus de-
Ouais, voilà, j'aurais pu-
Quelqu'un qui va te juger, qui va t'expliquer que c'est de ta faute et que...
Ouais, ou même me dire : Écoutez, vous avez qu'à prendre un benzodiazépine, ça va aller mieux dans deux semaines. Elle, vraiment, le seul traitement qu'elle m'a donné que j'ai pas pris pendant longtemps, c'était un antidépresseur.
En tout cas, elle me parle d'associations spécialisées en addiction, du Réseau d'aide aux toxicomanes, aujourd'hui, il s'appelle le RESAD.
Et donc là, je me dis : Ouais, je vais prendre contact avec ces gens. Donc de là, je commence une thérapie, donc une association spécialisée.
Et tout ça, ça s'est fait rapidement ou bien t'as...
Assez rapidement, ouais. Vraiment, les planètes se sont bien alignées et les choses se sont bien enchaînées. Donc, je prends contact avec cette psychologue, madame Cox, que je remercie.
Mais vraiment, elle m'a beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup aidé. Donc là, je fais une thérapie un peu de base. J'explique un petit peu tout ce que je t'ai expliqué un petit peu, en résumé, là, tout à l'heure, l'enfance, l'absence du père, ceci, cela.
Et là, en fait, j'accepte mon passé. Je l'accepte, je le digère, je comprends que ce que j'ai vécu n'est pas normal, qu'un petit garçon de huit ans, quand il vit ça, c'est difficile à vivre.
Donc ça m'aide déjà à avancer. Et je décide d'arrêter la cocaïne parce que je mesure un mètre nonante. J'étais à nonante-trois, nonante-quatre kilos.
J'étais à soixante-neuf kilos. J'avais un drôle de teint, j'avais une drôle de tête dans le sens où la cocaïne, ça te rend gris, en fait, ça te pâlit.
Mais j'avais des trucs rouges, tu vois un peu, le visage bouffi à cause de l'alcool. Je ressemblais plus à rien.
Donc ça, et je me dis : Bon allez, on va arrêter la coke parce que là, moi, je dormais plus. Et j'ai surtout aussi constaté que mon comportement changeait.
Comme je t'ai dit, je suis quelqu'un de rigolo, de bon délire. Et là, je devenais vachement agressif. Je commençais un peu à chercher la merde, la bagarre.
J'étais un peu à l'affût de ça. Je me dis : Non, c'est pas possible. Moi, je suis pas comme ça. J'ai déjà arrêté ça dans un premier temps parce que je sais ce que c'est en train de me faire.
Donc j'arrête la coke après une soirée de Nouvel An. Je me dis une date symbolique quoi, tu vois, pour dire voilà, il faut marquer le coup. Donc-
Bonne résolution.
Ouais, voilà. Ouais, c'est ça. Ouais, ouais, c'est ça. Je me dis : Je m'en mets une fois, une dernière fois plein le pif et après, on arrête.
Sérieux ?
Ouais, ouais, c'est ce que je me suis dit.
J'aurais tendance à penser que si tu t'en mets plein le pif, tu vas avoir très envie d'en reprendre après.
Oui, il y a de toute façon du cr-- mais voilà, j'étais déterminé. Je me dis : C'est la dernière fois, je m'achète, enfin, je vais pas donner le nombre de grammes parce que voilà,
mais je me suis acheté une chouette petite quantité pour une soirée de Nouvel An.
Et est-ce que ça a été la dernière fois ?
Ouais ouais, ça a fonctionné. Enfin, ça a fonctionné. Donc ce qui se passe, j'arrête, mais je compense avec l'alcool et le cannabis.
C'est, en fait, l'alcool et le cannabis m'ont fait un petit peu office de traitement.
Hum, plan B quoi.
Ouais, la compensation quoi. Et donc voilà, je suis très content, j'ai arrêté la coke, mais l'alcool reste là. Et en fait, entre-temps, au mois de janvier, je fais une demande d'admission dans un hôpital, dans l'unité polyaddiction.
Et on m'explique que voilà, la cure se fait en trois semaines et que pour rentrer en cure là, il faut avoir une entrée de posture.
Je dis : OK, vous savez, bon soldat, bon élève. Je reçois un papier avec différentes adresses. On me dit : Allez à Tournai, c'est chouette.
Je dis : Tournai, moi, je suis de Bruxelles, j'ai pas envie d'aller si loin. Donc je vais dans deux lieux de posture sur Bruxelles et les lieux ne me correspondent pas.
Je vois les trucs, le bâtiment, ça peut paraître méchant, mais le personnel, tout ça, il y a rien qui me parle.
C'est quoi ? C'est très, très vieux, très daté ?
Ouais, c'est des, c'est des-
Un peu glauque.
Ouais, c'est ça. C'est ça. C'est des anciennes maisons, machin, des trucs de... Beurk ! Enfin, beurk. Ça ne me correspond pas.
Il faut dire les mots comme ils sont, ça me correspond pas. Et donc, je me dis : Bah, j'ai réussi déjà il y a dix ans à arrêter le cannabis.
Je viens d'arrêter la cocaïne.
Bah, je peux très bien arrêter l'alcool.
Et je compte arrêter l'alcool et puis la beuh. Et donc je me mets comme objectif : OK. C'est toujours mieux de commencer un lundi parce que je dis toujours aux gens quand tu dis : « J'arrête mardi », mercredi de toute façon, ça va pas.
Donc je me dis : « OK, aujourd'hui, on est lundi. Aujourd'hui, je ne bois pas. » Enfin, c'est pas je ne bois pas, je ne bois pas avant telle heure.
J'attends vraiment d'avoir mon-- d'être rentré, de m'être mis à mon aise, d'avoir rangé, d'avoir fait ceci, d'avoir fait cela, de m'être alimenté parce que à un moment donné, je m'alimentais vraiment très très mal, très peu.
Donc je rentre chez moi, pour résumer le truc, je fais le ménage, je prépare à manger et d'un coup, ça va pas. Je me sens angoissé, difficulté à respirer, je me sens vraiment très étrange.
Je me dis : « Oh, si je suis essoufflé, c'est parce que je suis un petit peu occupé trop vite. Oh ben, je vais me rouler un petit joint pour un peu calmer le truc ».
Je ne voulais pas boire. Et je roule mon joint et je vois ma main qui tremble. Mais j'avais l'habitude des tremblements, j'en avais déjà eu le matin.
Ça, c'est commun quand t'es alcoolique d'avoir des tremblements. Là, je vois quand même ma main, elle tremble fort, je m'allume mon joint, ça ne me fait rien.
Et là, en fait, c'est plus ma main qui tremble, c'est mon-- enfin, si, ma main tremble, mais enfin, c'est plus trembler, c'est autre chose.
Et je prends ma main droite avec ma main gauche, je fais comme ça et là, tout mon bras part. J'ai comme des spasmes dans le bras et je lâche mon bras et je vois vraiment, enfin, j'ai tout le bras qui bouge.
Instinct de survie, coup de bol, enfin, je sais pas. J'ouvre le frigo, je bois quatre bières. J'ai jamais bu des trucs cul sec.
Je déteste salement le binging et boire trop vite. J'aime pas ça, c'est vraiment pas profiter du truc. Et là, je parviens à enchaîner quatre bières cul sec quoi, ou en deux fois.
Pa pa pa. Et là, je vois mon bras arrête de trembler. Je crois qu'inconsciemment, je sais ce qui se passe, mais j'ai pas les mots.
Dans la semaine, un jour, deux jours, trois jours après, je vois la psychologue et je lui explique. Et là, elle me dit : « Monsieur, vous pouvez pas arrêter de boire ».
Je dis : « Ben si, moi, je veux arrêter de boire ». Elle dit : « Non, non, vous pouvez pas parce que vous pouvez mourir ».
Comment ça ? Ça me fait un-- mais là, c'est un choc quoi. T'as envie d'arrêter quelque chose, on te dit : « Ne l'arrêtez pas parce que vous allez, vous pouvez delirium tremens ».
Moi, je pensais qu'un delirium tremens, donc avoir des hallucinations, c'était en surdose d'alcool alors que pas du tout, c'est en manque d'alcool.
Ou sinon, vous pouvez faire une crise d'épilepsie. Et ce que vous m'expliquez là, c'est les premiers symptômes d'une crise d'épilepsie.
Et là, ça me fait... Elle me dit : « Où ça en est votre demande d'hospitalisation ? » Et je lui explique ce que je viens de t'expliquer.
Elle me dit : « Il faudra peut-être trouver un autre endroit ». Et là, j'ai mon front qui tombe et je lui dis : « Mais moi, je connais un gars qui est hospitalisé à Chelles, à la clinique Sans Souci ».
Mais je me rappelais plus très bien pourquoi. Est-ce que c'était là pour addiction ou est-ce que c'était là pour des troubles mentaux ou autres ?
Donc en sortant, j'envoie un message au gars, on s'appelle. Il me dit : « Non, non, ils font cure, postcure au même endroit ».
Ok, tac. De nouveau dans la foulée, je téléphone à la clinique, je dis : « Bonjour »...
« Ah écoutez, vous allez sur le site, il y a un formulaire à remplir et après, il faut attendre trois, quatre semaines avant qu'on vous appelle pour un rendez-vous de préadmission ».
Je dis : « Ok ». Et directement, pa pa pa pa pa, j'ai répondu au questionnaire. Et donc trois semaines après, on me téléphone, on me dit : « Voilà, c'est la clinique Sans Souci.
Voilà, on voudrait vous voir pour un entretien de préadmission. Vous savez venir quand ? » Je dis : « Vous me dites le jour et l'heure, je viens.
Peu importe si c'est demain, après-demain ». Donc, je me rends. Là, de nouveau, j'explique un petit peu le parcours, les produits et tout et tout.
Et il me dit : « Voilà, j'ai pas de place directement » parce que ça, avoir une place directement le jour même, ça n'existe pas, malheureusement.
Ça, on pourra en reparler peut-être après.
En Belgique ou ?
Partout.
Partout ?
Partout, partout. Il faut vraiment un cas d'urgence très extrême, limite... si tu fais une tentative de suicide, là, tu peux te faire admettre directement en psychiatrie.
Mais sinon, c'est... Celui qui a ça, c'est qu'il a vraiment beaucoup, beaucoup, beaucoup de chance. Et donc il me dit : « J'ai pas de lit qui se libère avant un mois ».
Oui, oui, c'est des sacrés délais quand même.
Ouais.
Parce que par exemple, ce qu'on entend beaucoup chez les Américains, tu sais, c'est les interventions, les trucs où la famille, les amis viennent signaler à l'addict qu'il a quand même besoin d'aide et tout ça.
Et puis le week-end suivant, il est admis en hôpital. Et là, tu dis quand même-
Ça marche peut-être chez les Américains, mais en tout cas, je sais qu'en Belgique, en France aussi, non, non, non, non, non, ça n'existe pas.
Malheureusement, ça n'existe pas. Avec un peu de bol, ce sera plus rapide. Ils me disent quatre semaines, au bout de trois semaines, on m'appelle.
Il me dit... c'était un lundi, fin mai, le 30, je pense. Il me dit : « Voilà, un lit s'est libéré, tu peux venir le 2, le 2 juin ».
« Ok, à quelle heure ? » Et je crois qu'il m'a dit : « Les admissions, c'est vers... » Oh, je me rappelle même plus.
10 h 30, je crois, un truc du style. Et ça, je dis aussi souvent aux gens : « Ok, c'est long. Tu te mets sur la liste d'attente, mais à l'échelle d'une vie humaine, un mois, deux mois, c'est rien du tout ».
C'est vrai.
Mais c'est vrai que la personne, elle est dans l'urgence. On est dans l'urgence, on a envie de se faire soigner directement, mais malheureusement, c'est pas comme ça que ça marche.
Oui, mais surtout, il y a beaucoup de potentiel sur un mois, deux mois de faire une rechute, d'avoir envie de consommer de nouveau.
Consommer et d'oublier le rendez-vous. C'est aussi souvent le problème. T'as beaucoup de gens qui, malheureusement, comme ils sont dans la consommation, ils oublient le rendez-vous.
Moi, j'avais mis des pense-bêtes un peu partout quoi.
Tu disais que tu as eu beaucoup de chance d'être bien accompagné donc par cette généraliste, puis les psychologues que t'as vus.
Les crises d'envie, déjà, est-ce qu'elles sont encore présentes aujourd'hui dans ta vie ?
Oui oui oui.
Et comment est-ce que tu les gères concrètement ?
Donc le craving, donc crise d'envie, c'est une crise d'envie, donc à de l'alcool, à de la cocaïne, à du cannabis, à des produits.
Mais ça marche aussi pour un Snickers ou un Bounty, 'tend, voilà. T'as envie de quelque chose, t'as envie de ça.
La première chose que je me rappelle tout le temps en premier lieu, c'est que ça passe. Que t'aies faim, que t'aies soif, peu importe, ça dure dix minutes.
Attendez que ça passe. Un peu simpliste, mais moi, c'est la première chose aujourd'hui que je me rappelle : ça va passer.
Tu peux avoir du craving sur des idées permissives. Ça, c'est très... je l'ai expliqué là tout à l'heure à quelqu'un, c'est très particulier parce que t'as des idées qui te traversent l'esprit.
Et moi, j'en rigole parce que c'était... je dis : « Mais qu'est-ce qui est en train de se passer ? » En fait, j'étais... je vais me coucher et mon cerveau a joué contre moi.
J'échafaudais, j'élaborais des plans pour me trouver d'abord de la cocaïne. Je me suis dit : « Ouais, non, quand même, ça craint ».
Ok.
Après, j'ai échafaudé un plan pour me trouver du cannabis et le plan était très précis. Je savais qui appeler, quel métro prendre ou attendre.
J'ai fait le chemin, j'ai vraiment fait le trajet jusque chez le type. Et puis je me suis dit ouais non ça craint. Et puis après mon cerveau a échafaudé un plan pour aller me chercher de l'alcool.
Tu sais, comme entre guillemets, je suis un peu connu, enfin en tout cas on sait qui je suis plus ou moins, pas par rapport à TikTok, mais même par rapport au quartier parce que ça fait dix ans que je travaille au même endroit, les gens
peuvent me reconnaître.
Donc j'étais déjà en train de me trouver un plan pour aller chercher de l'alcool là où personne me connaît.
Mh.
Et de prendre mon sac à dos pour pas qu'on voie dans le sac en plastique transparent. C'était vraiment très très très précis.
Quand ça se passe, si t'as pas les bonnes stratégies, tu te lèves et tu vas à l'épicerie quoi. Le craving aussi, tu peux en avoir avec des stimulations olfactives.
Un type qui s'allume un joint dans la rue, ça sent très fort et rien que l'odeur peut te donner envie. Moi coup de bol, t'allumes un joint ici maintenant devant moi, je vais juste avoir des nausées.
Ok. Ok.
Je vais juste avoir des nausées, ça vraiment il y a ça qui vient donc je suis un petit peu à l'abri des stimulations olfactives, mais il peut y avoir des stimulations visuelles.
Je suis chez moi avec ma copine de l'époque, donc tout à fait récemment, on regardait un truc sur Netflix et le mec, il fait un cocktail qui ressemble à de la crème de whisky.
J'ai le goût en bouche et l'odeur dans le nez. Ça, c'est très spécial, ça donne envie. Ah oui, encore un truc aussi quand même, je vais le préciser, il peut aussi y avoir des stimulations auditives.
D'accord.
D'entendre parler du produit, le nom du produit.
Le son d'un briquet par exemple ?
Ouais, ça peut et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que dans beaucoup de groupes de paroles, on ne dit pas le nom du produit, on dit produit.
J'ai consommé tel produit. Pour éviter... parce qu'il y a des gens, ça va les mettre mal à l'aise d'entendre le mot-
Le mot produit.
Ouais. Moi vraiment, tout ça, c'est non. Moi, c'est vraiment plus les idées permissives et aussi beaucoup les émotions.
C'est-à-dire que si t'es hyper activé, donc t'es un peu trop en stress ou un petit peu trop euphorique-
Mh.
Tu peux avoir envie de consommer. Si t'es trop en dépression, t'es hypoactivé, tu peux avoir envie de consommer. Donc il faut toujours rester dans un certain cadre, ce qu'on appelle en psychothérapie la fenêtre de tolérance.
Donc première stratégie, évitement-
L'évitement.
Éviter que quelque chose puisse éventuellement déclencher-
Si je vois que la scène, c'est en train de trop me mettre mal à l'aise, je zappe ou je prends mon téléphone et j'attends que la scène, elle passe.
Ce qui marche très très bien, c'est tout ce qui est exercice de respiration. Surtout quand t'es un peu en stress, t'es un petit peu hyper activé.
Donc ça, je l'ai fait beaucoup au début. J'inspirais lentement par le nez, j'expirais lentement par la bouche et avec le ventre.
Ça, c'est très physiologique parce que ça fait baisser ton rythme cardiaque et ça masse tes intestins, ça marche super bien.
Mais ça maintenant, je l'emploie plus des masses. Ce que j'emploie beaucoup, c'est tout ce qui est en rapport avec la gestion des émotions.
Moi, je dis toujours que je me recadre.
Mh.
Je vais trop réfléchir par exemple au trajet pour venir ici, à comment va se passer l'interview et je vais anticiper tes questions, je vais déjà préparer nanana et je vais rentrer dans des trucs pas possibles alors qu'en fait ça sert à rien.
Je sais pas les questions que tu vas me poser. Enfin oui, tu m'as donné deux trois indications et puis voilà basta, je verrai bien comment ça se passe.
Donc je me recadre. Je me dis : ouh là, qu'est-ce qui est en train de se passer ? Bon là, je suis en stress, je suis anxieux. Pourquoi ?
Mh.
Ah, le tram était en retard.
Ok.
J'ai pas de contrôle sur les trucs de tram. Au final, le tram quand il arrive en retard, c'est pas si grave. Je peux toujours prévenir la personne chez qui je vais que je serai en retard.
Et est-ce que ça t'a coûté socialement ? Parce qu'on parle souvent de la réaction des proches, des amis, de la famille.
Comment est-ce que ton entourage a vécu-
Moi dans mon cas-
Tes différentes addictions ?
Dans mon cas vraiment personnel-
Ouais.
J'ai pas eu de souci. Avec ça, j'ai eu, vraiment,
je voyais bien que ma mère s'inquiétait pour moi. À un moment donné, je me rappelle d'une scène en particulier où je l'ai vue parce que j'étais arrivé chez elle en descente de cocaïne
et j'ai pété un plomb sur l'histoire avec mon ex et je me suis vraiment énervé tout seul en fait.
Ouais.
J'ai pété un câble tout seul et là j'ai vu qu'elle se demandait ce qui se passait, qu'est-ce qui lui arrive ?
Parce que je suis vraiment rentré dans une colère noire.
Mh.
Avec le recul,
c'était un peu ridicule quoi, tu vois. Mais sinon à part ça, socialement parlant, j'ai pas eu de souci. Ce qu'il y a aussi, c'est que les gens que je fréquente, je fréquente les mêmes personnes depuis des années, donc ils me connaissent aussi.
Ouais, Johnny boit son verre tous les jours puisque pendant dix ans j'ai plus consommé de stupéfiants, mais je consommais de l'alcool.
Ils savaient très bien que, bah déjà à jeun, je suis un peu exubérant.
Ben je l'étais pas beaucoup plus sous alcool. Ouais, enfin ça dépendait de l'heure de la soirée et du nombre de bières consommées, on est bien d'accord, mais voilà, ils savaient que...
Et même, c'était pas problématique. Comme je t'ai dit, j'étais pas quelqu'un... Si maintenant j'avais été quelqu'un d'agressif sous alcool, alors là, je pense que oui, les gens se seraient séparés plus rapidement.
Ce que je peux quand même dire, c'est que je me rappelle très bien qu'il y a une époque quand j'étais beaucoup plus jeune, j'ai quand même bien vu
que les personnes qui ne consommaient pas ou très peu d'alcool, je parle même pas de drogue, ne prenaient plus contact avec moi parce que je me suis quand même dit, ça, je me suis dit ça plus tard, je me suis dit à mon avis,
si j'ai plus de nouvelles de ces personnes, c'est parce qu'elles ont eu marre de mon
comportement ou de me voir dans cet état-là.
Mh.
Même que j'étais en train de rigoler, je pense que c'est pas très agréable pour trois quatre personnes de voir un mec bourré en fait.
Donc je sais qu'il y a quelques amis qui se sont naturellement, et je leur en veux pas parce que c'est tout à fait normal, qui se sont éloignés de moi en fait.
Mais sinon tu vois comme j'étais quand même entouré de personnes qui étaient dans le même délire que moi, avec le même sens de l'humour, etc, j'ai pas eu de perte à ce niveau-là, mais ça existe.
Ça existe parce que les produits isolent. La cocaïne par exemple, ça isole beaucoup, puisque de toute façon il y a plus que le produit qui compte.
Donc tu sais, ton père, ta mère, tes frères, tes sœurs
, à la limite, tu vas aller vers eux parce que t'as besoin d'argent
et quand tu vas les voir, tu vas mentir, ils savent que tu mens et puis ils te voient en train de t'autodétruire donc ils ont plus tellement envie de te parler.
C'est pour ça qu'il y a beaucoup de gens qui s'éloignent d'un usager parce qu'ils sont en train de voir en face d'eux une personne qui est en train de se tuer à petit feu et c'est compliqué pour un proche de voir quelqu'un dans cet état-là.
Mais en fait très concrètement, si je devais poser la question comme ça, donc on commence une consommation de cocaïne.
Mh.
Parce que tu expliquais tout à l'heure que tu t'étais intéressé dans le cadre de tes vidéos TikTok aussi à comment ça marche techniquement, qu'est-ce que tout ça.
L'addiction dans le cerveau, comment est-ce que ça fonctionne ? Qu'est-ce qui fait que ton cerveau dit : « OK, il m'en faut plus, il m'en faut encore ».
Ça dépend toujours des produits. Parce que t'as des produits-
La cocaïne, par exemple.
La cocaïne, ce qui se passe, en fait, c'est que... mais ça marche même avec d'autres produits. Mais après, il y a différents levels.
Mais en tout cas, tu consommes un truc-
Mmm-hmm.
Et ton cerveau kiffe la sensation.
La dopamine.
La dopamine. Ça augmente fortement ton taux de dopamine, mais très fort. J'ai pas le chiffre pour la cocaïne, mais par exemple, l'héroïne, ça augmente de deux cents pour cent ton taux de dopamine dans ton cerveau.
C'est des chiffres très très impressionnants.
Cocktail intéressant.
Donc t'as ça. Et donc ton cerveau kiffe la sensation. Je te donne des exemples un peu à l'arrache, à la louche comme ça.
Disons que tu passes une soirée, tu t'amuses bien, on te propose de la cocaïne, tu testes. Et waouh ! Je parle beaucoup plus facilement, je suis un mec timide, je vais parler aux meufs.
Ce que je raconte est vachement intéressant. Parce que sous cocaïne, tu résous tous les problèmes de l'univers. Tu résous les problèmes économiques de la terre entière, tu trouves-
tous les remèdes contre les maladies, tu vas trouver le moyen de combler le trou dans la couche d'ozone.
Voilà. Waouh ! Ah ouais, quand même. Oh, j'ai bien rigolé, etc, etc. Mais tu vas pas spécialement avoir envie de reconsommer le lendemain parce que de toute façon, tu dors pas, donc t'es pas très bien pendant trois jours.
Donc t'as peut-être pas spécialement envie de recommencer directement. Une semaine se passe, deux semaines se passent, tu te retrouves de nouveau dans un contexte festif et tu t'emmerdes un petit peu.
Et là, ton cerveau, la partie arrière, il te dit : « Mais la dernière fois avec la cocaïne, on a bien rigolé. Essaye d'en trouver ».
Et là, ce qui va se passer, hop, tu vois au fond de la salle, le mec de la dernière fois qui t'en a eu. Ah, truc muche, ça va ?
T'en as pas un petit peu ? En plus, tu vois, la semaine, t'as beaucoup bossé, t'es fatigué, tu sais que ça va te donner un coup de boost.
Et voilà, le truc s'installe. OK, tu reprends. Ah waouh, de nouveau, bonne soirée, machin. Et en fait, ce qui va déjà se passer, c'est que ton cerveau va associer deux sources de plaisir.
Le côté festif de la soirée, que ce soit chez des gens ou en discothèque, peu importe, en festival, en concert.
C'est une source de plaisir. Et la consommation de coke. Donc la troisième fois, on va dire, tu sais que tu vas aller à une soirée, mais tu vas pas attendre d'être à la soirée pour te trouver le produit.
Je résume, je schématise, c'est pas une science exacte non plus, mais moi, je trouve que ça se passe souvent comme ça.
Donc avant, tu vas téléphoner au type : « Ouais, tu serais pas m'en avoir ? » Comme ça, t'as directement ton truc à toi, quoi, tu vois.
Tu dois plus gratter. Et ma foi, cinquante balles une fois. Et là, voilà, ça commence à se mettre en place tout doucement.
Et c'est principalement dû à la-
Il y a une tolérance au produit qui s'installe aussi, j'imagine.
Ouais. Ça, c'est en fonction de chacun. L'accoutumance, elle finit toujours par arriver, mais...
Non, mais je veux dire, il nous en faut plus pour atteindre-
Parce qu'en fait, c'est ça. Le cerveau, en fait, il va toujours te pousser à retrouver la sensation de la première fois.
Donc la première fois avec un rail, c'était bon, mais la deuxième fois, il en faudra deux. Et puis il en faudra trois. Et puis pendant toute une période, tu vas être juste avec ton gramme, tu vas gérer ton gramme pour machin, passer ta soirée.
Et puis un jour, tu vas passer à deux et puis à trois. Et puis finalement, la sniffer, c'est plus assez fort, donc tu vas la fumer.
Enfin, donc, c'est pas sûr hein. Il y a des gens, voilà, à un moment donné-
C'est le parcours classique.
Ouais. Enfin classique. Il y a des gens, toute leur vie, ils vont la sniffer, ils vont jamais la fumer. Mais pour certains, dans certains cas, il y a parfois la recherche d'un truc plus fort, d'une sensation plus forte.
Moi, j'avais expliqué ça à quelqu'un. Moi, ce que je recherchais, c'était le tilt ultime. C'est-à-dire que quand tu prends ça, la cocaïne très précisément ou même les ecstasy,
il se passe quelque chose, évidemment, au niveau du cerveau, mais moi, je me rappelle très bien, il y a un truc qui démarre de la colonne vertébrale et ça remonte et tu te prends une espèce de décharge électrique dans le cerveau.
C'est un tilt. Moi, j'appelle ça un tilt.
Ok.
La perche ultime. Et quand ça, tu as, wouf.
C'est jouissif.
Ah, c'est incroyable. Enfin, c'est incroyable. Il faut le dire avec beaucoup de pincettes, mais sur le moment même, tu vis un truc qui est extraordinaire.
T'es dans un état d'euphorie tel qu'il ne peut plus rien t'arriver. Ta copine qui t'a quitté, plus rien à foutre, que tu sois seul, que tu sois machin, tout ça, t'en as plus rien à foutre.
T'es dans un état vraiment d'euphorie extrême et ça redescend, t'as envie de recommencer parce que t'as touché quelque-- moi, j'ai fumé de la cocaïne à un moment donné, j'ai fait ça une dizaine de fois
et j'expliquais que quand tu la fumes, donc l'équivalent du crack hein, fumer de la cocaïne, c'est comme fumer du crack.
Le crack, c'est juste que la cocaïne est déjà préparée pour toi. Je disais tout le temps, je dis : « C'est comme si tu parlais avec les dieux, en fait ».
Tu te retrouves dans un niveau, je le dis de nouveau avec beaucoup de précautions hein, avec beaucoup de gros guillemets, tu te retrouves dans un état de conscience tel, dans un état de bien-être tel que t'es assis à...
T'es avec les dieux, quoi, tu vois. T'es là, waouh. Mais bon, tout ce qui-- moi, je disais, voilà, c'est mon expression préférée hein : tout ce qui monte redescend.
Et au plus tu montes haut, au plus tu redescends bas. Ça, il faut être très clair, très clair sur le sujet. Mais au moment où tu atteins le pic-
Ouais.
De l'effet du produit que tu prends, et là, je te parle vraiment précisément de cocaïne et d'ecstasy, quand tu atteins ce pic, waouh.
Est-ce que c'est pas aussi que le niveau de base, entre guillemets, de dopamine, une fois que tu as atteint ce pic très très haut, finalement, le niveau de base te paraît être une abysse ridicule, un truc absolument in-
En fait, ce qui se passe, c'est par exemple, on parlait du contexte de soirée. Donc, tu consommes de la coke, des ecstas en soirée.
À chaque fois, t'es là : « Ah, c'est la fête ». Et puis tu vas te retrouver en soirée sans le produit. La même soirée, les mêmes personnes, le même DJ ou le même artiste, ça te paraît fadasse, sans intérêt.
Ça va vraiment te paraître... C'est même pas banal. C'est vraiment sans intérêt. Et tu te demandes même ce que tu fous là quoi.
Et là, c'est là que le piège est-- enfin, le piège est déjà refermé quelque part. C'est en ça que c'est très difficile quand tu arrêtes.
Parce que voilà, bon bah ton taux de sérotonine se régule, donc tu reviens, l'humeur revient, le sommeil revient, l'appétit revient, bla bla.
La dopamine aussi se rééquilibre. Mais c'est ça, je pense, qui empêche certains de passer l'étape du sevrage ou en tout cas de se décider à arrêter, c'est que pendant une période, en tout cas, la vie va te paraître vraiment...
Déjà, j'avais discuté de ça avec quelqu'un, c'était vachement intéressant. Voilà, donc t'arrêtes, t'as plus le produit en toi, t'es sevré.
Rien que de prendre les transports en commun, c'est un calvaire parce qu'en fait, tu redécouvres le monde. Tu sais, moi, j'ai toujours pris, pendant toute une période, pas le matin, mais le soir, j'étais tout le temps alcoolisé.
Quand j'ai rechuté,
partout où j'allais, j'étais stone. Donc tu sais, les transports en commun, tu vois les gens, t'es dans ton délire avec ta musique, t'écoutes ta zik, tu vois les gens, tu les trouves marrants, 'fin, ou tu les vois même pas, etc.
Et moi, je me rappelle très bien que la première fois que j'ai pris le tram pour aller faire des courses quand j'étais hospitalisé, ah, mais j'étais en stress.
Parce que mec, d'où sortent tous ces gens ? Pourquoi ils me regardent ? Que font-ils là ? Pourquoi sont-ils si nombreux ?
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Et ça, ça peut être un gros choc, tu vois. Parce que voilà, en fait, ton cerveau, il est en train de se rééquilibrer.
Et ce qui se passe aussi, c'est que quand tu vas reprendre une activité que tu avais associée avec la consommation, en fait, l'activité, déjà, elle va te procurer du craving parce qu'il te manque quelque chose.
Moi, tu vois, je mixe un petit peu, j'ai des platines, etc. Et j'ai toujours mixé défoncé. Toujours, toujours. Ou j'avais pris ça, ou j'avais pris ça, ou j'avais pris, ou j'avais tout pris.
Donc la première fois que j'ai allumé mes platines, j'ai tremblé comme une feuille, j'ai transpiré, j'en pouvais plus parce qu'il manquait ça et il manquait ça.
Et j'ai dû laisser passer du temps, tu vois, pour pouvoir refaire ça, pouvoir remixer parce que c'est chiant en fait.
En plus souvent, tu vas associer une activité créative à la consommation parce que tu penses qu'en fait ça booste ton truc.
Oui, 'fin, ça booste entre guillemets.
Ça booste ta satisfaction en fait.
Voilà, plus qu'autre chose.
Ouais.
Et moi, je trouve qu'en vérité, 'fin, moi, c'est ce que j'ai une fois expliqué à quelqu'un. Je lui ai dit : « Mais depuis que moi, j'ai arrêté, je suis beaucoup plus efficace quand je mixe.
C'est beaucoup mieux ». Parce que quand j'écoutais mes trucs que j'avais mixés quand j'étais défoncé, ça ressemblait à rien.
Ça ressemblait à rien. En plus, tu fais des erreurs, tu te trompes,
t'appuies sur les boutons qu'il faut pas. Mais c'est vrai que quand tu reprends une activité comme ça, ben il faut laisser un certain laps de temps parce que l'activité, elle te paraît vraiment sans intérêt.
Et ça, c'est toujours aussi un peu le piège, mais ça vaut la peine d'attendre parce que finalement, quand tu recommences, tu te dis : « Ah putain, ouais, c'est quand même mieux sans quoi ».
Et le public de la cocaïne, dans mon esprit, c'est un peu la drogue des élites. On est ici à Bruxelles, la bulle euro, tu sais, la Commission européenne, ce genre de truc.
C'était.
C'était, O.K.
C'était. C'était la drogue des élites parce que-
Ça devenu mainstream ?
Ouais, complètement. Ah oui, oui, oui, oui, oui. Mais ça l'a même toujours été.
En fait, il y a cette fausse croyance sur la cocaïne que c'est la drogue des élites parce que ça coûte cinquante balles pour même pas un gramme.
O.K.
Moi, à l'époque, dans les années 2000, c'était zéro neuf, donc t'avais même pas un gramme. Aujourd'hui, on est passé à zéro sept, zéro six, si t'as du bol, zéro huit.
Donc il y a un peu cette fausse idée qu'on se dit : « Ouais, c'est pour les élites parce que ça coûte cher ». Mais en fait, non, pas du tout.
Dans les années 2000, c'était un peu underground. Ce qui était très commun, c'était les ecstas, le speed, les amphétamines et tout ça, même le cannabis.
C'était facile d'en trouver. Maintenant, c'est devenu très facile. Mais la coke, c'était un peu, tu vois. Et puis ça coûtait cher, c'était pas encore tellement démocratisé.
Donc moi, comme je t'ai dit, j'ai arrêté pendant dix ans. Quand j'ai recommencé, je suis tombé des nues. J'en rigole parce que j'ai vraiment été choqué.
Tu commandes à manger sur Uber, hein, il te faut une demi-heure, trois quarts d'heure pour avoir ta pizza.
D'accord, O.K.
Tu vois où je veux en venir ?
Ouais, je vois où tu veux en venir.
Tu commandes ta coke. Déjà, ils font des-- bon, il y a des promos. Pas tous, mais il y en a qui font des promos. Ah oui, oui, du deux plus un gratuit, du un plus un gratuit.
Non, mais ça existe. Il faut s'en rendre compte de ça, hein. Et moi, j'en veux pas, moi, j'en veux absolument pas aux dealers, hein.
C'est la loi de l'offre et de la demande hein. Voilà, c'est comme ça. Mais sur dix minutes, quinze minutes, t'as ton truc quoi, tu vois.
Avant, il fallait te déplacer, il fallait aller là-bas, il fallait prendre ta voiture, machin, bidule. Maintenant, on te dit : « Il faut sur place ».
En trottinette, capuché.
Limite. Limite. Ouais, limite. En trottinette, en voiture, les mecs sont là. Donc, truc des élites, non.
Bon.
C'est vraiment une fausse croyance. Moi, je connais des gens qui étaient de mon niveau social, c'est-à-dire classe moyenne, qui étaient à fond dans la coke quoi, tu vois.
Et je connais même des gens qui sont encore moins, enfin, qui sont un cran en dessous. Moi, j'aime pas parler de ça, tu vois, les trucs-- enfin bref.
Enfin, j'aime pas l'expliquer comme ça en disant qu'il y a des couches sociales, mais c'est vrai, à un moment donné, il faut dire les mots.
Mais ce qui va se passer avec la cocaïne quand on parle de gens qui ont moins de moyens
financiers, c'est qu'ils vont plutôt alors se tourner vers le crack, qui coûte beaucoup moins cher ou l'héroïne qui coûte beaucoup moins cher ou la méthamphétamine qui coûte moins cher.
Mais de se dire : « Ça, c'est non. Non, non, non, non. » La cocaïne, c'est pour tout le monde.
Et en particulier, je pense, ces dernières années, ça a explosé, non ?
Ouais, ouais, ouais, ouais, c'est un truc de ouf.
Ça s'explique comment ?
C'est vraiment devenu très facile d'en trouver.
Ah oui.
Comme je t'ai dit, avant, il fallait vraiment avoir des contacts.
Mh. D'accord, oui. Ce marché s'est développé.
Il y avait des intermédiaires. Il fallait un intermédiaire.
C'est ça.
Parce que c'était rare que tu connaisses directement. Ou alors, il fallait être dans le milieu de la night et des trucs comme ça où tu connaissais directement un type ou tu faisais connaissance.
Mais il fallait souvent passer par l'intermédiaire. Maintenant, plus. Les réseaux sociaux.
Ouais, WhatsApp, tout ça, ouais, ouais.
WhatsApp, Snapchat pour pas les citer. L'autre fois, on m'avait dit : « Attends ». Non, voilà, aujourd'hui, il s'est passé quelque chose avec les réseaux sociaux qui ont facilité l'accès.
Telegram, Discord, des forums de discussion où tu vas pouvoir trouver beaucoup plus facilement.
Effectivement, il y a pas ça il y a 30 ans. Si tu pouvais t'adresser au Jonathan de 18 ans,
qu'est-ce que t'aurais envie de lui adresser comme conseil ou autrement dit, une façon de formuler la question, c'est : à quoi est-ce que ça ressemble
une campagne de sensibilisation, de prévention qui fonctionne bien ?
Parce que quand on a 18 ans, je pense qu'on a plutôt envie de pas trop écouter ses aïeux et de penser qu'on sait mieux et que voilà tout ça.
Du coup, comment est-ce qu'on fait ? Qu'est-ce qu'on dit pour faire comprendre que il faut peut-être-
Si on parle de ça, et c'est d'ailleurs aussi en partie pour ça que moi, je me suis dit : « Ce serait intéressant de le faire à mon-
Sur TikTok, ouais
...à ma petite échelle, à mon niveau », parce qu'en fait, rien n'est fait. C'est très périodique. Voilà, on vient de passer les fêtes, hein, donc on a eu beaucoup de campagnes Bob, Responsible Young Driver, hein, machin, tous ces trucs-là.
C'est très bien. Tu revois des publicités maintenant qui parlent de ça ou des petits reportages au journal parlé, RTBF ?
Non. Donc, ils font des campagnes de prévention qui sont très ponctuelles et qui ne sont pour moi pas très efficaces. C'est des petites piqûres de rappel deux fois par an pour l'alcool
Je dirais que institutionnellement, effectivement, les campagnes tout ça bof. Par contre, il y a de plus en plus de voix, de témoignages, de-
Ça oui.
De biographies-
De livres, de tout-
Mais il faut que le message soit diffusé aussi. Je trouve qu'en Belgique, le message est très peu, voire mal diffusé.
Je trouve qu'en France, il commence un petit peu-- il y a beaucoup d'émissions de témoignages.
Mmm-hmm.
Il y a pas mal de témoignages maintenant aussi sur Internet avec des plateformes style Konbini ou ce que fait Guillaume Pley ou d'autres, Real Media ou des choses comme ça.
Eux, voilà. Et c'est très bien. Mais enfin, je vais le dire, je le dis comme ça, c'est très privatisé, le truc, tu vois ?
Mmm-hmm.
C'est parce qu'un gars comme moi a décidé de le faire ou que quelqu'un comme toi a décidé de dire : « Tiens, je vais interviewer le mec, on va en parler ».
Et c'est tant mieux, tant mieux que ça existe, vraiment.
Ouais.
Parce qu'à un moment donné, c'est un problème de santé publique-
C'est ça.
Qui doit être pris aussi en charge par l'État. Je suis désolé, c'est comme ça. Et l'État ne fait rien. Oui, on va une fois un petit peu mettre un petit sou là pour de la prévention avec l'alcool au volant,
mais l'alcool, ce n'est pas qu'au volant, tu vois.
Oui, il faut faire de la prévention là-dessus parce que c'est très dangereux de conduire sous influence, mais on pourrait un petit peu élargir le champ de vision, le champ d'action.
Enfin moi, c'est toujours la réflexion que je me fais. On fait beaucoup de trucs contre le tabagisme et tant mieux.
On a fait le paquet unique avec des grosses photos. Pourquoi on le fait pas avec l'alcool ? Ou est-ce que tu as déjà pris une bouteille de whisky, une canette de bière où c'est marqué « l'alcool tue » ?
Non. Tandis que le tabac, le tabac tue. Et c'est vrai, le tabac tue. Sur une bouteille d'alcool, c'est marqué où ?
Ils te marquent juste « à consommer avec modération ».
Oui. Ça te semblerait légitime, toi ? Tu penses-
Mais je comprends même pas que ce soit pas encore fait.
Mmm-hmm.
Moi, c'est un truc... Si, je t'assure, je ne comprends pas. Oui, on t'augmente les taxes. Bah oui, mais c'est pour faire rentrer de l'argent dans les caisses de l'État.
Mais je ne comprends pas pourquoi il y a rien qui est marqué sur les bouteilles de vin, les bouteilles de... Je ne comprends pas.
Est-ce que, je sais pas. Moi, j'ai le sentiment qu'une majorité de la population arrive à maintenir une consommation
relativement saine, que sur toutes les personnes qui ont bu du vin ces trente dernières années, je pense que les gens qui sont morts à cause de ça...
Oh, tu serais étonné, tu sais. Il y a des chiffres, il y a des chiffres. Par exemple, voilà, tu parles de décès.
Mmm-hmm.
L'alcool tue, c'est une évidence. On peut donner des chiffres, mais il y a tout le reste. Combien de personnes se font hospitaliser par an pour des problèmes d'alcool ?
Ouais.
Ça, il faudrait sortir les chiffres. Quelque part, il y a déjà un truc de positif, c'est que l'alcoolisme est reconnu comme une maladie chronique.
C'est déjà pas mal. La mutuelle peut intervenir. D'ailleurs, moi, j'ai reçu une indemnité de mutuelle pour maladie chronique et c'était pour l'alcoolisme.
Ça, on va pas, voilà. Je trouve qu'en Belgique, par contre, si on parle de mutuelle rapidement, on est très bien couvert, tant mieux.
Mais est-ce qu'on parle des pers-- moi, je pourrais t'en parler pendant trois, quatre jours d'affilée hein, de l'alcool et des hôpitaux psychiatriques, parce que moi, j'y suis passé, mais parce que j'en ai vu beaucoup aussi.
J'ai vu beaucoup de gens qui étaient en clinique, là où j'étais donc, qui étaient là pour un problème d'alcool et/ou de cannabis et/ou de cocaïne.
Mais il y avait souvent l'alcool. Il y avait souvent l'alcool avec. Et le nombre de rechutes, de gens qui vont passer un mois, deux mois, trois mois, six mois, neuf mois même comme moi, en clinique, cure post cure, et qui, à la sortie, rechutent.
Parce que rien n'est fait pour encadrer ces gens. Si, les choses existent.
Mmm-hmm.
Mais l'accès à l'information... Moi, comme je t'ai dit là tout de suite, quand j'étais chez le médecin généraliste, elle m'a parlé d'une association spécialisée en addiction.
Je ne savais pas que ça existait. Je ne savais pas que ça existait. Sur Bruxelles, il y a beaucoup d'assos. Il y a beaucoup d'assos.
Tu peux vraiment trouver, entre guillemets, très facilement une structure qui va pouvoir t'aider. Mais si tu ne sais pas que ça existe, enfin...
Tu vois, oui, ils font des petites affichettes dans le métro. Il faut t'arrêter, te poser pour voir que c'est une affiche qui parle d'une association, Infor Drogue ou Rézad ou le Pélican ou Bon, le Bon Plan, Dune.
Enfin, je peux t'en citer des noms hein, mais pour avoir accès à ça, comment tu fais ? Et si en plus on parle de personnes en précarité, on va te dire : « Oui, mais il faut chercher sur Internet ».
Mais un gars en précarité, il a pas de smartphone. Donc comment il va faire des recherches sur Internet ? Enfin, tu vois, c'est là que je trouve que les pouvoirs publics sont inactifs, en fait.
Ils s'en foutent. Oh, les gens n'ont qu'à se débrouiller. Les structures existent, les ASBL existent, la plateforme de ceci existe.
Bah ils ont qu'à, ils ont qu'à chercher pour trouver. Je suis désolé, c'est un problème de santé mentale, c'est un problème de santé publique.
Et je pense que franchement, les élus politiques, le gouvernement pourrait faire beaucoup, beaucoup plus en termes de prévention, mais de vraie prévention et de vraie, comment je vais dire ça ?
J'ai fait un groupe de travail là-dessus pour améliorer la communication vis-à-vis des personnes qui ont un problème d'addiction.
Mmm-hmm.
Parce que demain, tu te rends compte ou n'importe qui se rend compte qu'il a un problème d'addiction.
Ok.
Vers qui il peut se tourner ? J'ai un problème avec ça.
Mmm-hmm.
J'aimerais arrêter, mais je dois aller où ? Parce que la première chose en général à laquelle une personne peut penser, c'est voilà, comme c'est un problème de santé mentale, hôpital psychiatrique.
Google, déjà.
Oui, oui, c'est vrai. Mais qu'est-ce que tu dois marquer dans la barre de recherche ?
Oui.
Il y a tout un truc, tu vois, parce que tu le dis toi, mais c'est pas tout le monde. Toi, c'est parce que tu as eu le réflexe de le dire maintenant, mais tout le monde n'a pas ce réflexe-là.
J'ai un problème d'addiction, je me tourne vers qui ? Tu vas voir ton médecin généraliste. Le risque, c'est que le médecin généraliste dise : « Prenez un Xanax ».
Le Xanax va pas t'aider. C'est une béquille. Moi, je te dis, j'ai eu de la chance. Elle m'a dit : « Allez, il y a des associations qui existent, allez les voir ».
Je trouve, entre guillemets, pas normal que ce soit mon médecin généraliste qui m'en ait parlé. J'aurais dû avoir cette information-là avant, via d'autres canaux.
Tu vois des affiches, mais l'affiche, elle est toute petite. Parfois, elle est mal faite. Puis il faut oser appeler.
Enfin, moi, je trouve que dans les médias belges, il y a rien qui est fait. Ou alors c'est très stigmatisant. On va faire des trucs et c'est très stigmatisant.
Oui, on associe toujours l'addiction à la précarité et on va plus te parler du problème d'insécurité. C'est des gens qui vivent à la rue, ils causent des nuisances.
Et je reviens sur Matthew Perry dont on parlait tout à l'heure. Il y a cette émission où il était, je crois, sur CNN ou je ne sais plus quelle chaîne où-
Je crois que j'ai vu la même chose.
Ouais, il tombe sur un gars en face de lui qui lui explique que, ben, mais c'est de ta faute si tu prends d'alcool et tout ça.
Il suffit de pas le faire quoi, tu vois. Et ce truc de
pas comprendre que c'est un système, que c'est une pathologie, que c'est un truc sociétal tout ça et penser que c'est juste, tu vois, la faute, c'est un péché que tu as commis.
Il y a beaucoup de fausses idées. Moi, je pense qu'il faudrait passer par là d'abord. Déstigmatiser le truc quoi, en expliquant que la personne qui est en face de toi, on va prendre l'exemple concret d'une personne en précarité,
le gars qui est allongé là, Gare du Midi, d'autres stations, Botanique et tout.
Donc tu vois les mecs, ils dorment. Ah regarde-moi celui-là, l'autre défoncé puis la pisse tu vois.
Mh.
Oui, mais pourquoi ? Déjà, tu connais pas son histoire.
Ouais.
Tu connais pas son histoire. Qu'est-ce qui a fait qu'il en est arrivé là ? Pose-toi les bonnes questions. Demande-toi pourquoi il consomme.
En plus, ce qui se passe souvent, c'est que les mecs boivent de l'alcool la journée pour dormir et prennent des excitants style cocaïne ou crack pour rester réveillés la nuit, pour pas se faire voler, pour pas se faire agresser parce que ils
Moi parfois, j'ai l'impression qu'ils prennent le problème à l'envers.
Ouais, mais il faut les mettre dans des centres d'accueil. Oui, mais c'est pas ça la solution, tu peux pas mettre, d'ouvrir des centres partout pour mettre ces gens-là, il faut les réinsérer.
Il y a une vraie politique, il y a une vraie culture à installer. Le gars qui est là, il est malade, il est en souffrance.
C'est irréel de penser que ce mec-là a voulu cette situation-là. C'est irréel. Non, personne n'a envie de se trouver dans cette situation-là.
Mais le parcours de vie, les tuiles qui peuvent te tomber sur le coin de la tronche, t'ont conduit à ça.
Tu tombes, enfin, j'allais dire, tu tombes pas du jour au lendemain à la rue. Oui, c'est possible, mais c'est un long déclin.
La personne vit un long déclin. Et pendant ce déclin, en fait, je suis persuadé que cette personne, à un moment donné, elle a envie de s'en sortir, elle a pas envie de...
hein. Mais elle trouve pas les ressources. Elle a pas accès aux ressources de soutien dans le sens où elle sait pas où aller les chercher, elle sait pas où aller les trouver.
Je vais te donner un exemple qui m'a un peu interpellé. L'association Dune édite un petit carnet qui s'appelle Le Bon Plan.
Et dedans, t'as plein de lieux de liens, des endroits où tu peux aller prendre une douche, des endroits d'associations spécialisées en addiction, en lien avec tout, même les violences conjugales, enfin des trucs comme ça.
Il y a beaucoup, beaucoup, beaucoup de trucs sur Bruxelles, mais les gens le savent pas.
Pour les gens qui nous écoutent maintenant, qu'est-ce que tu aurais à leur conseiller très concrètement ?
Chose que je tiens d'abord à dire, c'est que c'est difficile d'empêcher quelqu'un de vouloir faire ses propres expériences.
Mh.
Je trouve que ce qui marche bien, c'est de ne pas diaboliser l'usager et certainement pas le produit.
Parce que si tu commences à dire à quelqu'un : « Si tu prends de la cocaïne, tu vas mourir, tu vas te retrouver comme ça, comme ça, comme ça, comme ça.
» Le gars, bon ben, ça peut marcher.
Oui. Ou par opposition, il va-
Ou te dire : « Bon, tu sais quoi ? L'autre, il m'a expliqué ça, il m'a dit que c'était le diable. Je vais tester. J'ai envie de faire ma propre expérience ».
C'est ça, ouais.
Tac. Et le mec, il constate qu'en fait, tout ce que tu lui as expliqué, il n'a pas, en tout cas au début.
Ouais.
Il n'a pas. Ouais, c'est vrai, j'ai pas bien dormi, mais ouais, je me suis senti trop bien, machin, bidule. Donc en fait, l'autre, là, ben en fait, c'est un mytho, il raconte que des conneries, il ment.
Mh.
Donc moi, ce que-- Voilà, expliquer tout sans tabou. Maintenant, si je devrais m'adresser au moi de dix-huit ans, je t'avoue que je serais pas trop bien qualifié parce que c'est compliqué, mais au moins de-- voilà.
Moi, ce que je pense qui est important de faire, c'est de la prévention et de la réduction de risques. Il y a des gens qui veulent faire que de la prévention et dire : « C'est mauvais, c'est mauvais, c'est mauvais ».
Mais je pense que la réduction de risques est très importante aussi.
Réduction de risques, donc des salles de shoot, par exemple.
Ça et de dire très clairement : « Écoute, quand tu vas prendre ça, tu vas te sentir comme ça, comme ça, comme ça. Tu vas kiffer.
Oui, tu vas kiffer. Mais derrière, il va se passer ça, ça, ça et ça. Donc, si t'as envie de faire ta propre expérience, fais-le.
Je suis personne pour t'en empêcher, mais
fais-le alors en toute connaissance de cause. Sache que en commençant avec ça, le risque potentiel est très élevé que tu te retrouves dans telle situation, dans telle situation et qu'au final, tu te retrouves là-bas,
très loin, très bas.
Maintenant, t'as envie de le faire, fais-le. Je suis personne pour t'en empêcher, vraiment, mais fais-le en connaissance de cause.
Réduis les risques, espace les prises, n'en prends pas trop. Et voilà. Et maintenant, si toi, tu es dans une addiction, par exemple, TikTok, cannabis, il y a moyen de-- ça peut s'arrêter.
Ah.
Mais voilà, sache que tu vas arrêter, tu décides d'arrêter demain, tu vas te retrouver en sevrage.
Ouais, ça sera pas facile.
Donc, tu vas avoir dur. Mais rassure-toi, un sevrage, il y a un début, un milieu, une fin.
Donc, c'est pour ça que je dis il faut en parler sans tabou et qu'il faut un peu viser large, ne pas diaboliser et vraiment prévention et réduction de risques.
Moi, je pense que les deux ne vont pas-- l'un ne va pas sans l'autre.
Oui, ben plus que de la prévention, surtout, surtout de l'information.
Information, oui, oui, tout à fait. Oui, voilà, c'est ça. C'est ça.
Parce que-
C'est ça.
C'est vrai qu'on a plus tendance à nous dire la drogue, c'est de la merde.
Voilà.
Et pas tellement expliquer-
Déjà, pourquoi c'est de la merde.
Ouais, voilà. Mais c'est ce qu'on a fait aujourd'hui.
Ouais, je pense qu'on a plus ou moins réussi l'exercice, même bien. Mais dis-toi qu'au bout du truc, tu récupères une vraie qualité de vie.
Et pour récupérer cette qualité de vie, moi, je peux t'aider. Tiens, t'as un rendez-vous pour ton psy ? Ben t'as pas téléphoné.
Viens, téléphone maintenant. Vas-y, viens, on le téléphone à deux.
T'as rendez-vous quand ? T'as rendez-vous le vingt-trois. Ah ben tu sais quoi, moi dans mon agenda c'est marqué le 21 déjà, je te dis écoute, fais attention, prends pas trop de trucs pour que tu sois quand même un minimum frais.
Et le 23, je suis devant ta porte hein, t'as intérêt à descendre. Pour que la personne, tu vois, elle sache qu'elle est soutenue parce que les usagers ont besoin de soutien.
Ça, c'est vraiment capital à comprendre. Les usagers ont besoin de soutien plus que de leçons de morale. Ça sert à rien de faire une leçon de morale à un gars qui consomme de la cocaïne ou du cannabis ou de l'alcool, ça sert à rien, il s'en fout.
Maintenant, t'as un problème avec ça ? Ok. Tu sais quoi ? Viens. Il existe ça, il existe ça, il existe ça. Tiens, voilà le numéro de téléphone.
Tu laisses un peu infuser, décanter. T'as téléphoné ? Non. Viens, attends, tiens, je passe demain chez toi, on va chercher sur Google ou je vais t'aider à remplir les documents.
T'es pas en ordre de mutuelle, viens, tu sais quoi, je viens avec toi, on va aller à deux à la mutuelle. Comme ça moi, je peux parler pour toi si tu veux.
Ah ok, d'accord. Si la personne accepte, tant mieux, mais voilà. Et alors tu peux aller avec elle, l'accompagner dans son parcours, etc.
Ça, c'est, il faut, voilà, c'est ça.
Ouais, ouais.
Ça, c'est important.
De l'accompagnement et donc tu parlais de structures qui existent à Bruxelles. Avant de se quitter, est-ce que t'aurais des adresses, des noms, des institutions à plugger pour-
Il y en a plein.
Peut-être les personnes qui nous écoutent et qui se disent : « Tiens, ben justement, peut-être... »
Moi, je suis beaucoup en contact avec eux. Il y a la plateforme de Bruxelles de la santé mentale.
D'accord.
Eux, ça coûte rien de les contacter. Venez dans nos locaux ou vous savez quoi ? Attendez, je vais vous préparer une réponse, je vous enverrai les adresses par mail.
Par exemple, si tu cherches un hôpital psychiatrique ou un bon psychiatre, enfin tu vois, ils peuvent un petit peu t'aiguiller.
Infor Drogue, c'est lié à ça ou...?
Infor Drogue, c'est à Arlois, c'est à côté de l'ambassade italienne. Ils peuvent aussi aiguiller les gens, recevoir des personnes.
Ou leur téléphoner n'importe quand.
Ouais, ouais, ouais, c'est ça. Il y a Dune, l'ASBL Dune, qui elle, se situe entre Porte de Hal et Hôtel des Monnaies. Il y a la MAS.
La MAS, c'est du côté de la gare du Midi.
Mais tu dis des noms, mais tu ne dis pas à quoi ça sert. Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Euh, c'est toutes des associations spécialisées en général en addiction, avec ou sans lien avec la précarité.
D'accord, ok. T'as parlé d'un truc qui s'appelle Pélican aussi.
Le Pélican, ça, c'est une association spécialisée en addiction. Eux, ils font de l'accompagnement individuel et il y a un groupe de parole.
Ils font même des réunions, par exemple, un père et sa fille ou une mère et son fils. Ils font des trucs un peu thérapie familiale quoi, c'est ça.
Planning familial aussi hein. Tu peux très bien contacter n'importe quel planning familial, eux aussi peuvent t'aiguiller.
D'accord.
Les services sociaux de ta commune aussi. Le CPAS peut aussi t'aiguiller. Je pense aussi au RESAD, comme ça se prononce hein, R-E-S-A-D, Projet Lama, qui existe aussi.
Il y a comme ça tout un truc. Il y a une application à installer, un peu compliquée à installer, mais elle existe. Ben c'est l'application du Bon Plan.
D'accord.
Les gens vont sur Internet, ils tapent Le Bon Plan Bruxelles. C'est l'application, ben qui regroupe toutes les associations que je t'ai expliquées dans le petit bouquin.
Mh.
Il faut juste en fait, j'explique rapidement, il faut installer une application pour télécharger des applications parce que quand tu vas sur le Play Store, c'est un peu compliqué.
Enfin, si les gens qui m'écoutent ont envie d'en savoir plus, ils peuvent me contacter, il y a pas de problème, je leur expliquerai bien comment ça fonctionne.
Mais voilà, il y a vraiment, il y a vraiment beaucoup.
Donc pour les Wallons qui nous écoutent, venez à Bruxelles.
Attention, en Wallonie aussi, il y a beaucoup hein. En Wallonie aussi, il y a hein. En Belgique, je trouve qu'on est pas mal.
C'est plus facile à dire qu'à faire, mais c'est un premier pas. Faites ce premier pas, vous verrez, avec un peu de travail, de la patience, il y a vraiment réellement moyen de s'en sortir.
Je le dis parfois comme ça un peu bêtement, si un pelo comme moi y a réussi, je pense que c'est à la portée de tout le monde.
C'est un très beau message hein, c'est bien.
Moi, c'est ce que-- Il y a quelqu'un qui m'a dit : « Ouais, mais il faut pas dire ça ». J'ai dit : « Mais si », parce que moi, j'ai longtemps été dans un sentiment d'échec, un sentiment de solitude.
Vraiment, le sentiment d'échec, je l'ai vécu pendant très longtemps. Et je me suis dit : « Il faut que je réussisse au moins un truc dans ma vie, c'est ça ».
Mh.
Et c'est possible de le faire parce que les ressources existent et je le dis comme ça.
Je trouve ça très beau.
Merci.
Rappelle-moi, donc tu fais ça depuis combien de temps ?
La cocaïne, j'avais arrêté donc en 2000, début 2022. Donc la cocaïne, ça va faire...
Ben deux ans du coup.
Ouais, deux ans. Ouais, deux ans. Ouais, c'est juste deux ans. Et l'alcool et le cannabis, ça va faire 19 mois. Depuis le 2 juin 2022.
Ben félicitations.
Merci beaucoup, Guillaume. Merci beaucoup.
Comme je disais, le message que tu portes est vraiment très inspirant et-
Et les gens ne doivent pas hésiter à me contacter par mail. Sur TikTok, il y a mon adresse mail. J'ai donné mon nom là tout de suite sur TikTok, donc c'est JoeWolf9791.
Et je mettrai le lien vers l'association et vers ton TikTok.
C'est gentil. Mais il faut que, ça, j'explique tout le temps. Il faut pas hésiter à m'envoyer un message privé. Je réponds à tous les messages privés.
Peut-être pas dans les 24 heures, peut-être pas dans les deux heures. Je me fais un devoir de répondre aux gens qui prennent la peine de me contacter par message privé.
Ça, d'office, ils peuvent compter sur moi pour un petit conseil ou un petit coup de boost ou je suis là pour ça.
Très bien. Eh bien...
Merci beaucoup.
Merci pour ta présence.
Merci à toi.
Merci pour ton message et on se retrouve bientôt pour un nouvel épisode. Un grand merci à Jonathan qui est venu passer 70 minutes avec moi.
Je suis très curieux d'avoir vos retours sur cet épisode, donc dites-nous ce que vous en avez pensé de son témoignage. J'ai mis nos adresses e-mail et son compte TikTok en description.
Et j'ai mis aussi toutes les références
aux différents centres qu'il a cités en fin d'épisode. Pour la suite, comme je vous le disais, pas mal de politiciens sont prévus, que ce soit des députés européens, des présidents de parti, des gens de l'opposition.
Vous allez le voir, c'est un super programme. Et j'aimerais aussi faire quelque chose sur l'intelligence artificielle et le TDAH.
Ça, c'est pas encore tout à fait aligné. Mais en vrai, ce que je dois absolument gérer, c'est le fait que je regarde le programme et je vois que c'est super déséquilibré niveau parité homme-femme dans les invités.
C'est une difficulté en soi hein, sur laquelle je reviendrai sûrement peut-être dans un épisode bonus plus tard ou je vais le faire maintenant d'ailleurs.
Clairement, c'est assez—
Voilà, par exemple pour les politiciens, si je veux inviter des personnalités les plus en vue avec, voilà, des gens qui sont des super bons clients pour une interview, bah, dans les faits, c'est surtout des hommes.
Et puis, que ce soit chez les universitaires ou les consommateurs de stupéfiants ici, hein, avec Jonathan, c'est de manière générale surtout les hommes qui sont à l'aise pour prendre la parole.
Donc ouais, c'est une difficulté en soi. Je me rappelle que, je crois que c'était la deuxième saison ou la fin de la première saison, il y a déjà quelques années, quatre ans.
Je me rappelle, j'ai pris conscience du déséquilibre dans les invités et je m'étais bougé pour vraiment faire un épisode avec un homme, un épisode avec une femme et alterner comme ça à chaque fois.
C'est plus simple, plus facile à dire qu'à faire. Parce que vraiment, moi, j'essaie de travailler, entre guillemets, très impulsivement avec les sujets qui me passionnent.
Et voilà, des fois, les sujets sont vraiment monopolisés médiatiquement, publiquement et même en allant chercher chez les experts par les hommes.
Et puis, éventuellement, on peut trouver une femme qui a l'air,
qui a l'air compétente, qui a l'air pertinente. Mais voilà, on— C'est pas moi, je sais pas, je suis pas en mesure de savoir si elle sera, entre guillemets, un bon client pour un podcast.
Donc c'est une difficulté en soi parce qu'il y a un déséquilibre de base dans l'espace médiatique, et il faut essayer de le compenser, mais c'est pas facile.
Mais voilà, c'est quelque chose dont je suis conscient et je vais me bouger. On va trouver une solution, pas d'inquiétude.
On se retrouve très bientôt pour un nouvel épisode. Promis, il n'y aura pas de pause de deux mois cette fois-ci. Et en attendant, si vous êtes resté jusqu'au bout du podcast,
vous pouvez remonter dans les archives en allant jeter un œil au futur nouveau site de Septante Minutes Avec,
qui n'est pas encore prêt à être révélé au grand jour.
Bon, puisque vous êtes là, puisque vous êtes resté au bout de la septantième minute du podcast, je vais vous donner tout de suite l'adresse.
Vous pouvez aller jeter— Vous pouvez avoir un aperçu rapide en allant sur beta.septanteminutes.be, beta, B-E-T-A, point septante minutes en toutes lettres, point B-E.
Chut, c'est un secret. C'est un site sur lequel je bosse depuis très longtemps. Vous allez voir qu'artistiquement, il y a des— J'ai osé certaines choses.
Très curieux d'avoir votre avis et normalement, il sera en ligne, j'espère bientôt. Je dis ça depuis très longtemps, donc en fait, sans doute que ça va mettre encore des mois.
Mais voilà. On se retrouve très bientôt, comme je le disais, pour un nouvel épisode. Salut !